blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an
entire non-fiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
pakman so there are many people who have
been
hoping for waiting for praying for
even the demise of joe biden and they
are really going to have to keep waiting
quite frankly at least for now
as joe biden's approval rating has
jumped
to 63 up two points from late march
this is not about cheerleading or
uh uh praising when there is nothing to
praise
but it is about understanding why joe
biden's approval rating is up again
but also importantly the areas where
it's not
because they actually are cause for
concern
and show that the republican strategy
has actually worked
where they have applied it and we're
going to get to all of that but the data
is that a new poll from the associated
press and norc
now has joe biden at 63 percent approval
overall
96 approval among democrats trump would
often tout
96 approval from republicans we could
never find that data
joe biden really has 96 approval from
democrats apnorc
poll 62 approval from independence and
yes
a paltry 23 approval
among republicans but that is
dramatically higher
than democratic approval of trump
throughout donald trump's presidency
these are notable republican approval
numbers
for how how high they are even at 23 and
overall
this puts joe biden at 63 approval now
in this poll the number of americans
who are optimistic about the country's
direction is up to 54
we had a different poll yesterday which
had that number
at 40 up from 20 this poll
uh asked the question a little
differently and has joe uh
has uh the country at 54 thinking
we are moving in the right direction
this is the highest of
any ap poll dating back to the beginning
of donald trump's presidency in other
words the country
is more optimistic today than at any
time
during the trump presidency what is
pushing joe biden's approval rating up
the issues are handling of the covid
pandemic
health care and the economy according to
this very same poll
some of this is logical some of it is
more notable for example
democrats tend not to poll as well
on the economy despite the fact that the
economy by every
indicator does better when a democrat is
in the white house
rather than a republican that's
interesting 71 percent
of americans approve of joe biden's
handling
of the pandemic and we are getting
closer and closer to ending the pandemic
i'm going to have the latest numbers for
you
probably tomorrow maybe thursday the
last week has seen even faster declines
in cases even faster declines in deaths
fortunately an uptick in vaccination and
we will get to that a little bit later
in the week
even 47 percent of republicans approve
of joe biden's handling
of the pandemic 57 percent of americans
approve
of joe biden's handling of the economy
62 percent
approve of joe biden's handling of
health care so far
which has been mostly prioritizing the
affordable care act and a few things
tied in with coveted stimulus not that
much has actually been done yet as far
as health care goes
so consider that disconnect right now
joe biden's approval rating
is high because of his handling of covid
and the economic stimulus and yet zero
republicans not few zero republicans
voted for that very same coveted
stimulus that is part of why joe biden
is popular
even with a relatively high number of
republicans
now on the flip side joe biden is not at
50
approval on two major issues gun policy
and immigration this is super important
because these aren't two issues on which
joe biden has just
naturally struggled to build approval
those two
issues gun safety and immigration
are the issues that republicans have
chosen
to attack joe biden over this means that
the republican counter narratives the
right-wing media
counter narratives do work they do
influence
people's thinking and people's opinions
and beliefs almost from day one
not literally day one i think it was day
five of the biden presidency
republicans and peter ducey from fox
news and others
started the counter narrative on
immigration the border is chaos
there's kids in cages there's kids
separated from their parents all of the
things
they didn't care about when trump was
president and it has worked
it has worked to build the belief that
there's a crisis on immigration and that
at least to some degree uh it's joe
biden's fault
um there were i think it was back in
june 28
of americans believed there was an
immigration crisis now it's 48 percent
not much has actually changed other than
republicans have been hammering this
issue
second issue on which joe biden is not
doing well
is gun control biden has done almost
nothing on gun control
understand that after that recent string
of mass shootings joe biden did announce
he was going to be going after the
government will go after ghost guns a
little more
and some very tame like very very minor
gun safety issues some of which may not
even lead to anything because they were
biden saying
please study this and tell me what to do
so we need to understand that when you
and i
start to see these narratives pop up on
fox news and newsmax and
lindsey graham is talking about it and
whatever we know they're fabricated out
of thin air and we know there's often
nothing to them
but they work and they can be a drag on
presidential approval now
in terms of joe biden's 63 approval
overall
yeah to some degree the american people
are realizing that some things are going
well republicans
have been complaining that joe biden's
tweeting is too boring
and too conventional that's a sign they
don't have much to complain about we
covered
that segment on fox news last week which
i called
is the economy doing too well under
biden and that's when you know things
are going okay economically
and it's pushing joe biden's approval up
beyond where trump ever was during his
presidency remember
trump never achieving 50 approval even
once during his presidency joe biden
was at 61 now at 63
that's good but we have to understand
that whatever they can get
purchase on traction on and right now
that's guns and immigration
they will use it to try to win in 2022
and we simply have to be ready for it i
do want to spend
a few minutes covering the latest
rantings from former president donald
trump
as we learned this weekend and as we
talked about on yesterday's show
donald trump is very much in control of
a huge portion of the republican party
and trump's agenda-setting power is
going to influence
how the republican party positions
itself for 2022 in 2022
hopefully joe biden can get much done
between now and november of 22.
uh but those second two years of joe
biden's presidency
are going to determine the legacy of the
administration in terms of the totality
of what gets done
now donald trump as you may know has a
blog
it was promoted as a new social media
communications platform
uh was going to be life-changing it was
revolutionary it turns out it's just a
blog
and the blog posts read like tweets so
this is kind of like
sad trump twitter as maybe we should
call it
and over the last 48 hours donald trump
has published multiple
screeds to sad trump twitter and if they
are any indication
about the likely direction and focus
of the republican party over the next
period of time
it's looking very humiliating and i'm
unclear whether there's a strategy here
at all
never mind a potentially winning
strategy so let's jump right in donald
trump starting out
uh even sunday's mother's day turning it
into something political
saying happy mother's day to all it will
all come back bigger and better and
stronger than ever before do not worry
now the economy is doing
uh as well as it has done throughout the
entire pandemic
new stock market records inflation
remains low
vaccination is doing well biden's
popularity
63 uh more than half the country thinks
we're going in the right direction so
trump is teasing that someday we'll get
back to things being good things have
improved dramatically since donald trump
left
from then trump going on to tweet sorry
to blog about the kentucky derby but
very late
saying so now even our kentucky derby
winner medina spirit
is a junkie j-u-n-k-y now that's
yeah anyway that's the wrong spelling
but that's fine this is emblematic of
what is happening to our country the
whole world is laughing at us as we go
to hell
on our borders our fake presidential
election he's still
going with that and everything else
then trump attempting to weigh in on
the liz cheney situation once again and
this relates to that pro
versus anti-trump split in the
republican party
that we talked about in some detail
yesterday trump saying quote the house
gop
has a massive opportunity to upgrade
this week from
war monger liz cheney to gifted
communicator elise stefanik
elise has intelligence an endorsement
from
american patriot brandon judd and the
national border patrol council
she has an a plus from the nra and she
loves
our veterans we need someone in
leadership who has experience
flipping districts from blue to red as
we approach
the important 2022 midterms and that's
elise
she knows how to win which is what we
need now the theme
here is cancel
those who aren't on message with the
republican party
these people claim to be against
cancellation and yet
they are very quickly going to cancel
romney cancel liz cheney uh and trump
wanting to play king maker for 2022
then trump issuing sort of like a
political endorsement also part of this
he wants to play king maker narrative
saying quote lieutenant governor dan
patrick is a great fighter for the
people of texas he has stood up for
life liberty the second amendment border
security our military and our vets
and our god-given freedoms he is
governed by conservative principles of
low taxes and careful spending
always doing what is best for his great
state and for america
texas should re-elect him he is
outstanding and has my complete and
total endorsement now dan patrick is one
of the most
disgusting uh state-level officials
up there with greg abbott from texas and
you know so many others christie gnome
and and so many others
he's the guy who early in the pandemic
said listen uh grandma would sacrifice
herself for the economy
uh by which he met the stock market and
uh it went downhill from there so trump
already
aligning his endorsements and they are
of the worst most horrible people
then trump going after mitt romney
continuing the republican party split
saying after being loudly booed at the
utah republican party convention
utah's weber county censured rhino
mitt romney in the strongest of terms
washington county republicans
also censured romney in april he is bad
news
for our country clearly trump
will be involved in the 2022 election
and then lastly
another one of these delusional election
fraud posts trump writing
the major michigan election fraud case
has just
filed a bombshell no they haven't
pleading
claiming votes were intentionally
switched
from president trump to joe biden the
number of votes is massive and
determinative
this will prove true in numerous other
states all republicans must unify and
not let this happen
if a thief robs a jewelry store of all
its diamonds
the 2020 election the diamonds must be
returned
the fake news media refuses to cover
the greatest election fraud in the
history of our country
they have lost all credibility but
ultimately they will have no choice
so he's still going and we could write
it off as just delusions
but most of the republican party still
believes it
they still believe joe biden didn't
really win
the 2020 election so the question is
can this work to win them 2022
it lost them to the house in 2018 it
lost them the senate in 2020
it lost them the white house in 2020.
can it work
in 2022 or is it destined
to give them the same disaster let me
know what you think we
are doing a one day huge membership
special
on memorial day uh want to be notified
it's very easy
just get on my mailing list at
davidpakman.com on memorial day a
glorious day
you will get an email telling you
exactly how to take advantage
of this incredible one-day membership
special we'll take a quick break and be
back right after this
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly what one of
my favorite apps lets you do it's called
blinkist and what they do is take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book in just
15 minutes i recently read a brief
history of time
of course by the great stephen hawking
this is a book that i have been aware of
for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy science
they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
slash david pakman i put the link right
underneath this video
all right we we have so much to cover
today that i'm not even going to waste
time
talking about the uh world famous
benefits of membership i'm going to skip
that and jump right into material
because there's just too much to cover
and this is really interesting
economically we have
all over the map opinions about a recent
statement by joe biden
about so-called free riders on the
unemployment
insurance enhanced unemployment
insurance that is currently available
now for framing for context any social
insurance program
has the possibility of free riders
people on
food stamps who shouldn't really get
them but they're using
business expenses to artificially lower
their income so that they qualify for
food stamps or whatever or
people who choose not to work or not
work as much
in order to qualify for medicaid instead
of working
and earning more and paying for their
health insurance for example
now no honest person who understands any
social insurance program will tell you
that free riders don't exist they do
exist
but the point is when we think about
macro economics
uh instead of the micro of such programs
if the programs are finely tuned if the
benefits are well calibrated
if the means testing is appropriate and
enforced
assuming it's a means-tested program you
basically don't worry about a few
anecdotal free riders because they are
relatively
few and the program overall at the
societal level at the macroeconomic
level
is a positive thing for the economy
that's the general approach to any
properly administered
social insurance program right now
we do have a unique circumstances with
so-called
enhanced unemployment benefits through
the federal government during the
pandemic now normally unemployment
insurance and benefits are a state thing
states determine
the level of benefits they vary by state
they tend to be higher in states with
higher wages and higher cost of living
and that's
fine and that's how it it all works in
this case and this is a very rare
situation because of the pandemic
the federal government came in and they
dropped an enhancement
on people in many cases disconnected
from what they were earning
in the job they lost due to the pandemic
so you can always say there are
some people choosing unemployment
insurance instead of working
we don't worry about it because
unemployment insurance
runs out the benefits aren't huge
there's not that many people who even
could earn more
from the unemployment insurance than
from working
it's also um just a
a truth about humans that people
generally want to feel
useful and they want to work so while
sure
anecdotally there might be some people
in normal circumstances that have
figured out a way
to earn the same or almost the same from
staying home
it's not really a macroeconomic concern
in this particular moment because of the
enhanced
federal unemployment there are more
people
who theoretically could earn a little
more
from staying home and collecting the
normal state unemployment benefits
plus the enhanced federal benefits then
from going back to the job
that they had that that is theoretically
possible right now and anecdotally it's
happening
so joe biden gave a series of remarks
yesterday on the economy
and talked about how jobs numbers from
april were short of what was expected
and one reason that's being cited is
that because of this enhanced
unemployment
there are more people than usual turning
down jobs
so that they can stay home and collect
that sweet sweet enhanced unemployment
so joe biden says he's going to deal
with that let's take a listen
well look fifth thing we're going to do
we're going to make it clear that anyone
collecting unemployment
who is offered a suitable job
must take the job or lose their
unemployment benefits
there are a few coven 19 related
exceptions
so the people aren't forced to choose
between their basic safety
and a paycheck but otherwise that's the
law
now there are already a ton of things to
talk about here
first of all as joe biden says this is
already
the law all of these unemployment
systems in each state
sometimes it's by phone sometimes it's
online there's different ways that it's
done
you regularly have to answer questions
like are you looking for a job
did you apply for jobs have you been
interviewed were you
offered a job that you turned down so
joe biden is not creating any new law
here
joe biden is saying we're going to
enforce the rules on unemployment
interesting it's really difficult to
enforce
people are self-reporting there's
relatively little confirmation or
oversight
there's no central database where the
government could determine
you said you weren't offered any jobs
but you were offered one and you
declined it it's basically the honor
system
uh so this is really just kind of like a
message from joe biden
i don't really know how much will be
done as a result of it but let's listen
to a little bit more
i know there's been a lot of discussion
since friday since friday's report
that people are being paid to stay home
rather than go to work
well we don't see much evidence of that
that
is a major factor
we don't see that that look it's easy to
say
the the line has been because of the
generous unemployment benefits
that it's a major factor in labor
shortages
americans want to work americans want to
work
as my dad used to say a job's about a
lot more than a paycheck
it's about your dignity your place in
the community
being able to look your kid in the eye
and say everything's going to be okay
i think the people who claim americans
won't work even if they find a good and
fair
opportunity underestimate the american
people
so we'll insist that the law is followed
with respect to benefits
but we're not going to turn our backs on
our fellow americans
22 million people lost their jobs in
this pandemic
through no fault of their own they lost
their jobs to a virus
and to a government that bungled its
response to the crisis
and failed to protect them we still have
eight million fewer jobs than we did
when the pandemic started
okay so you get the idea so there have
been two reactions to this one reaction
has been
great get these free loaders off of
unemployment
you have restaurants you have other
businesses that can't find workers
so the story goes because people are
happier staying home
and making enhanced unemployment rather
than going back into work
the reality is this is statistically
rare
it's possible because of enhanced
unemployment there are anecdotes about
it
but i worry that by even doing this
joe biden is buying into this right wing
narrative that we have no particular
reason to accept we don't have to accept
that right wing narrative
but there's another side to this which
many people are reacting with
if the wages are so low at these jobs
that you do make more staying home on
unemployment
isn't that a sign that maybe the wages
are too low raise the wages in order to
attract
employees now remember this is not
normally as much of an issue when there
is not the enhanced unemployment this is
really a transient issue enhanced
unemployment from the federal government
is going to be ending
in all likelihood later this year but
what does it say about the wages being
paid
another practical difficulty is biden
says
you know you can't turn down a suitable
job and continue to collect unemployment
who determines if it's suitable if you
lost a job making
sixty five thousand dollars and you're
offered when making 13 dollars an hour
is that suitable do you lose
unemployment benefits if you don't
accept
that job so i think that this is
basically unenforceable
i'm curious to see what enforcement
there will be i think enhanced
unemployment is going to end before
there's any real enforcement
and much of the problem is that i see
joe biden by doing this as playing into
a republican criticism which is barely
valid
again any social insurance program
anecdotally you can find instances of
anything the question is
at a macro level is that actually a drag
on the program
enhanced unemployment has been a huge
saving grace for so many people and my
concern is biden's just buying into it
too much and it's not really the problem
that republicans claim it to be
let me know what you think so yesterday
we talked about
a newsmax reporter named emerald trying
some gotcha questions on white house
press secretary jenn saki
failing completely falling victim
to basic questions from jen saki like
who said that when she said many people
are
saying so after we did yesterday's show
there was another press briefing and jen
saki was
i guess we might call it confronted by
fox news reporter peter ducey
who tried another one of these lines of
questioning
to try to get her and make gensake look
bad it is so sad that this is the level
of discourse that is pervading what
could be pretty informative press
briefings
but let's jump right in and like
yesterday we can play
you know spot the logical fallacy we
already covered
uh joe biden's announcement that to
prevent people from
turning down jobs to choose unemployment
over the job
they are going to be cutting
unemployment benefits from people who
turn jobs down
this question was asked just before joe
biden made that uh statement take a look
and on the economy so employment only
rose by about 266 000 jobs in april out
of 7.4 million
or so job openings how does the white
house know that people are just choosing
not to
apply for jobs because the extra
unemployment benefits are so good
well first let me say that we have
looked at the data and
secretary yellen referred to this on
friday or talked about this on friday
we don't see much evidence that the
extra unemployment
insurance is a major driver in
people not rejoining the workforce we
actually see the data
and our analysis shows that
lack of vaccination the lower rate which
is why i refer to the data in the week
that it was taken
it has an impact child care has an
impact school's reopening has an impact
but there is also the need to pay a
livable working
wage and that's one of the reasons the
president will talk about that this
afternoon
so peter ducey is flame framing this all
as
there's tons of people choosing not to
work because they make more
unemployment how do you know that
how do you know that the reality is that
every social insurance program
has some free riders but if the program
has the right balance
of benefits and safeguards and
enforcement you don't worry
about the free riders because of the
overall net benefit of the program
the problem is republicans have this
strict father morality
where they want to make sure every
individual is receiving what they
deserve and you don't deserve
unemployment benefits if you turn down a
job
we're concerned with the macro economics
of it i don't really care
if there's someone really motivated to
collect unemployment and not work
as long as the system overall is
providing the economic benefit it's
designed to provide
gensake accurately points out you know
for most people this is not the issue
it's issues of child care or low wages
or being unvaccinated that are
preventing people from getting back into
certain jobs
let's continue but as bank of america
economists who are cited in a
bloomberg story say anybody making less
than 32 thousand dollars a year is
better off
financially just taking the unemployment
benefits so is the white house creating
an incentive just to stay home well
again
uh the majority of economists internally
and
externally of the white house don't feel
that unemployment insurance something
that was
done at a time where to help unemployed
people
get through a very difficult economic
downturn during a pandemic
is a dr is the a major driver in uh in
our unemployment data that there are
other factors
bigger factors that were contributing
have been contributing to the numbers we
saw on friday
that's what we're working to address and
that's where we think our solution
should be focused so
the fallacy here is cherry picking of
data
again we have decades of data about
social insurance programs
they're i'm like a broken record there
are always some free riders some people
who prefer the benefits rather than
doing
what's required to get off of those
benefits
most economists understand that overall
the enhanced unemployment has been a
huge part arguably as big a part as the
cash payments
in stimulating the economy during the
pandemic peter's one example
of a bank of america economist who spoke
to bloomberg
doesn't change the big picture
understanding of how these programs
function economically here's a little
more of the line of questioning
last one really quick the commerce
secretary says the main reason that
people are staying home
is fear how does the white house know
that people are scared what is that
based on
well i think what she was referring to
is the fact that there were
there was a much lower vaccination rate
just a month ago
and that people are fearful about
getting sick
they are fearful about whether they're
going to have the conditions to be
healthy whether they can send their kids
to a child
center whether there is a child care
center so those are all factors that are
consistent with
the examples and reasons i just provided
okay so
in a sense it's not an unreasonable
question but understand that
bigger context i'm the first to admit
and joe biden admitted it yesterday in
his announcement
the way enhanced unemployment is set up
there are some people
who could turn down a job
because the enhanced unemployment makes
it more lucrative to stay home
they're dealing with that it's transient
it's temporary enhanced unemployment is
ending
the conversation is backwards first the
wages
sometimes being turned down aren't even
livable wages some of these wages
full-time 40 hours a week don't get you
the median apartment or even
a 20th 20th quintile 20th percentile
apartment
in the cities in which the jobs are
located that's number one
so is the problem that unemployment
benefits are too high
or is the problem that the wages are too
low secondly
when someone gets uh what someone gets
from unemployment
enhanced or not is pennies on the dollar
compared to what huge corporations got
in covid cash
from the eidl program and the ppp
programs and those turned into
exponentially bigger slush funds
than what anyone on unemployment
insurance is getting so as usual
hard questions about the wrong issue
about individual social insurance
programs
essentially nothing about the corporate
welfare and that's
typical you know the justice system
overwhelmingly focuses on street crime
rather than white collar crime
and questions and concerns about social
insurance programs overwhelmingly
focus on the individuals who receive
very little
rather than the corporations that
receive very much typical
we'll have more on this on the show's
instagram page so make sure you're
following us there
davidpakmanshow on instagram follow me
at david.pakman
the david pakman show depends on your
support and the easiest way
is through membership which includes the
world famous bonus show
as well as commercial free audio and
video streams of the show
just for members sign up today at
joinpakman.com
coupon code saves you 40 better 21.
today i'm going to be speaking with
jamal greene who teaches constitutional
law
at columbia university and also is
author of how rights went wrong
why our obsession with rights is tearing
america apart
it's so great to have you on i
appreciate it good to be here thanks
so maybe just to frame our conversation
you know one of the things
i've talked about over the last few
years is that a lot of these movements
that um claim to be or are ostensibly
about rights and about
staking a claim to a right exercising a
certain right
they seem to do this in the absence of
an understanding that with rights come
responsibilities and that the claiming
of rights in a vacuum seems to be
untenable and in some cases an
impossibility sort of in modern
modern society i'd love to kind of first
hear your thoughts a little bit about
that and the idea of
are rights something that we should be
exploring
in a vacuum absent any cultural societal
reality
or is that context absolutely crucial to
thinking about rights
well i certainly think that rights are
embedded within a society and
and we actually have a very long
tradition in the united states
of thinking about rights and their
limits as something that
is a collective exercise that's actually
how the framers thought about rights but
we've gone away from that
vision and gotten to a place where
and i think this is where your political
movements come in we tend to
to use rights as political leverage
because we tend to think about them in
almost absolute terms as
as you say in a vacuum kind of
disconnected from all else
that once you claim a right then you get
to win right so the whole game becomes
can i claim a right can i get a relevant
decision makers
sometimes courts to to say that i have a
right and
that's what's going to win me my
political battle and we i think we need
to get back to
thinking about rights in political terms
which is to say
in terms of of being part of a society
what is a framework where we can think
about situations where
rights seemingly conflict or
when we're talking about one's freedom
or right to
do something versus someone else's
freedom or right
to be free of that something what what's
the framework that we should be applying
to those conflicts
well one of the things i emphasize in
the book is that rights
inherently conflict they always conflict
and you can if you think about your
right to form a society and to pass laws
right so government
is is designed to protect rights and
there's also of course another side
where there's individuals who are
claiming
particular rights against what
government does so there's constantly
conflict you've got to have a strategy
for managing that conflict
in the u.s our legal system has
developed to a place where
the way we the way we manage it is to
kind of pretend it doesn't exist
pretend the conflict isn't there and
that one side is right and the other
side is wrong so you got to pick who has
the right
in any particular case whereas in
actually many other countries
in fact most other countries the way in
which the legal system tends to respond
is through
i'll use a legalistic term called
proportionality but what it really means
is that
you kind of background the question of
who has the right you just assume that
rights exist on both sides of a lot of
legal questions
and you focus much more heavily on what
is the government doing
what kind of problem is it trying to
respond to what kind of evidence
is it relying on what kind of
alternatives are available to it
is it acting totally disproportionately
or is it acting basically reasonably
those are the kinds of questions that we
typically ask when we're asking about
is this just is this fair and those
questions are totally consistent with
the the notion that
that their rights involved because
you've gotta
what i say in the book is mediate
between different claims of rights on
multiple sides of a conflict and get at
really factual questions of well what's
what's actually going on here we don't
need to to get into kind of a
legalistic questions of what does the
first amendment mean or what does the
constitution say those questions don't
get us very far
in answering questions about rights
conflicts we've got to get into the
into the factual details so i mean to
take a case maybe many in my audience
will be familiar with this infamous
gay wedding cake case from from the
state of colorado
one interpretation of that would be that
it's a question
of the right of a business owner
to make decisions about how they want to
operate their business
and the right of the couple wanting the
cake not to be discriminated against
on the basis of sexual orientation it
might it could be framed as a right
versus a right
all sorts of different participants have
reframed it where
there's other ways to think about it one
could say well it's a judge or jury
choosing as to which whose rights reign
supreme but is it not that simple
i think it's not that simple and it's a
it's a fascinating case because i think
it really does
kind of burrow down on this on this
problem where i actually think there's
even more than two um sets of rights
involved so there's the rights of a
baker who wants to
to decide which which weddings he bakes
cakes for right and he's claiming a
religious right and also a free speech
right because his cakes are really
artistic so he
right he thinks that it's a way of
speaking there's the right of the couple
to not be discriminated against as you
say david
uh and then there's the right of the
people of colorado passed a law that
says don't discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation so
they've got right to um at least the way
i
frame it so there's rights on all sides
and you could think of it
in the most kind of uh binary terms as
a judge or jury's got to pick you know
whose rights count
but there actually are a lot
lots of overlap in how each of the sides
in that case understood the rights of
the other side
so the couple actually believed that a
a baker can choose whether to bake a
cake for someone he ideologically
disagrees with he can decide not to bake
a cake the couple agreed with
that the baker agreed that he actually
can't discriminate on the basis of
sexual orientation
in in baking his cakes he didn't claim a
first amendment right to avoid
discrimination
what the disagreement was was a much
more narrow disagreement
about whether refusing to bake a cake
for a same-sex wedding
counted as as as discrimination on the
basis of sexual orientation
because the baker said i don't care who
my customers are i just don't want to
participate in this wedding and so
that's an ideological
dispute according to him he's not
actually discriminating against any
people
and the couple said well no if this had
been a a
opposite sex wedding you would have you
would have baked the cake and so that is
discrimination but that's actually a
pretty narrow
conflict and what i'm trying to suggest
in the book is that judges really
need to focus on on the narrow
part of the conflict rather than trying
to decide you know
do we care more about religious freedom
or do we care more about equality for
same-sex couples
those are values conflicts that we're
not going to resolve in a court case and
shouldn't try to resolve but we can
actually get much closer together
if we focus on individual details in
fact i guess that's the tricky thing
where
it's very common that you will have a
case
that starts with what appears to be a
decision or a conflict between some
broader values
about how society or an economy or a
culture should operate and by
the time it gets to either the initial
court decision
or even on an appeal some subsequent
court's decision
it ends up being something very very
narrow and i think to some degree that
is a source of frustration for many
people
who would like to have these broader
issues resolved sort of like once and
for
all and it doesn't happen because the
courts end up
very narrowly making making a decision
as you point out
how should the broader questions be be
dealt with because
when they're dealt with so-called
democratically
either by by you know a ballot
initiative or by the legislatures that
we elect
um often it's still not permanent in
that
then it's undone uh at the next
opportunity i mean like how should a
society deal with the broader question
well the the broader questions of values
conflicts i think the first thing i'll
say is they shouldn't be resolved by
courts
okay and and this is the this is
rights conflicts are ultimately
political conflicts or conflicts between
people who have fundamental
disagreements with one another
and it's okay to have fundamental
disagreements with one another that's
what makes us
um human uh and in some ways the core of
the book
is to say look the reason we we disagree
about rights
is not because one of us is right and
the other is wrong
because some of us are angels and others
devils because we're different
people we have different values
different commitments and
when you when you overlay a legal system
onto that kind of disagreement
the legal system has to figure out
how do you construct rules that enable
people to live together
and to stay invested within the
constitutional system so i actually
celebrate uncertainty at least to a
degree
i celebrate not resolving rights
conflicts for all time
because that that that means that the
constitution doesn't protect or doesn't
care about
one or the other side of really
important values conflicts
i don't think that's the way a legal
system should operate i think you try to
mediate those
conflicts through politics and when i
say politics i don't always mean
legislative politics or ballot
initiatives
i mean other kinds of institutions
journalists are
are engaged in acts of politics when we
go to
when we have you know social media
conversation that's politics
schools are engaged in forms of politics
politics is
is uh is is constructing a political
culture
a culture of understanding uh
what the core of our disagreements might
be understanding the perspective
of other sides and trying to work
towards a solution
that's what that's what political
negotiation
looks like and that that again that
doesn't necessarily happen
in legislatures although that's the sort
of ultimate
uh that's the ultimate you know power
wielder is the legislature but before
you get to the legislature there's a
whole lot of political conversation that
has to happen that gets shut off
if we think that the way to resolve our
political conflicts is to give them to
courts
who are going to make kind of legalistic
abstract decisions that don't get us
very far to addressing our conflicts
last thing i want to ask about you know
during the run-up to the 2020 election i
received a lot of emails from viewers
and listeners particularly in europe who
said you know i'm following this
election in the united states
and i'm struck by how much talk there is
of people asserting rights
the discussion of my right to free
speech my right to vote my right to a
gun etc
saying that in in their countries this
idea of asserting rights just is not
a it's not a narrative in elections and
that they found that there was
they were curious about like how did
this become such a thing in american
politics where people are
constantly talking about rights and
asserting rights is there some
particular
history to that in the united states
that we can point to about how this
issue of
the asserting of rights became such a
political discussion that in other
countries it simply is not
so so i'll say a couple of things so one
is is
that in in europe they do care about
rights but they just don't
necessarily think of rights as kind of
trumps that kind of
overcome everything else and that's
what's really i think different about
our political culture
and i i think that i try to tell this
story in the in the book and kind of the
first third of the book
uh it doesn't come from the founding
which is what we often tell ourselves
the founders
um had a much more communitarian view of
rights than
uh than modern americans do it really
comes out of the 1960s
in the post-civil rights era legacy and
it's a it's a it's a complex story but
that what it boils down to is is a
history with race
and with the particular pathologies the
particular problem
of of people who are being racially
discriminated against in overt
ways being kind of the paradigm of
rights in america
right the the the core right is the
right against racial discrimination
and that's not something you mediate
right that's not something where you say
well
you know let's see what the
segregationists think and then we'll
kind of see what the
other people think it doesn't lend
itself to mediation because one side of
that dispute
is completely bad faith oppressive um
abusive actor but you can't dissociate
all of government with you know anytime
my right is at stake that means the
government's being abusive or oppressive
um that's not most rights um that's not
most rights conflicts and so
i think we need a language in which we
can talk about ordinary political
conflict
that doesn't take the form of this is
let's see if this is just like jim crow
or let's see if this is just like
mccarthyism we've got to take
rights conflicts on their facts and
actually think about what the
government's trying to accomplish
and whether it's something that is
considered to be legitimate within our
tradition
very uh very well said uh the book as
we've been uh mentioning
is how rights went wrong why our
obsession with rights is tearing america
apart
we've been talking with the author of
the book professor jamal greene
it's so great to have you on i really
appreciate your time great to be here i
enjoyed the conversation thanks
the david pakman show depends on the
support of our viewers and listeners and
one way to keep us going is through
patreon
where you can pledge as little as one
dollar per month
or as much as you want at patreon.com
david pakman show great perks and
benefits as well
read about him yesterday was a super
interesting media criticism day
we had guests on both fox news and
newsmax
call out fox news and newsmax for their
perpetuating
lies on the air later we'll look at
newsmax but let's start with fox news
these are really really good clips
randy weingarten is a lawyer a labor
activist labor leader
president of the american federation of
teachers member of the afl-cio
fox news's martha mccallum brought randy
weingarten on to talk about
critical race theory being taught in
schools this segment is not going to be
about critical race theory i just did a
whole segment two shows ago
on critical race theory you can find it
on the friday podcast or on youtube so
this is not the topic today
that was the topic of the segment we're
going to look at and check out how
randy just goes right at fox while being
interviewed by martha mccallum
for them spreading misinformation and
martha mccallum doesn't like it
big believer in celebrating diversity
in action and actually looking at and
helping
look at people's lived experience but if
you're
really talking about misinformation now
martha and i hope you are
i really would hope that fox would
really look at what happened in this
election and
how we can because every social studies
teacher is wrestling with this
discern fact from fiction we have to do
that
yeah we have well we have a president
president biden
uh was elected in 2020 i i think that
all of that
is is quite clear um so i'm not sure why
you you know are so concerned with with
that
part with that particular moment in
history every election is significant
nobody is hiding anything under any
rocks here but
i but i do have you know the fact that
you have two martha mccallum is just
so confused about why randy weingarten
would bring up telling the truth about
the election oh i don't know maybe
because
of the months of spreading and inviting
guests to spread disinformation about
the election
which partially played a role in getting
things to the fever pitch that
culminated on january 6th with the trump
riots maybe that has something to do
with it martha
and then this is really great even
though martha mccallum
immediately tries to start talking over
randy weingarten
in her next opportunity randy comes
right back
and does the same thing on the topic of
vaccination reporting
and this time martha mccallum gets more
upset
i would hope fox says to all these
people
that don't want the vaccines that think
there's a problem
why don't you and i do things together
to get our kids back to school this
is what we need to do we have to stop
the misinformation
we have to stop the disinformation
as you know you know as you know
uh many of those students were back
without being vaccinated and the cdc
said it wasn't required for teachers or
students to be vaccinated to go back to
school
so children are a separate issue peop
every family across america is going to
make that decision
about their children we know that these
are going to be widely available for
them which is great so people have that
option
that indignant attitude is just too much
fox hosts get
absolutely exasperated when they are
confronted by guests
for what fox news does says and puts out
on the airwaves and we've covered those
incidents before
she got defensive really quickly and
randy weingarten
really getting under martha mccallum's
skin there and if you're watching these
clips
rather than just listening you may
notice the facial
expression change just instantly
on martha mccallum's face when the call
out starts to happen
if guests did this more regularly on fox
news
i think fox would have to change its
approach maybe they'd have to switch to
pre-recording interviews to prevent this
maybe they wouldn't even have these
guests on i don't know if that's better
right to some to some degree
it's good to have people who talk sense
on fox news it might pierce someone's
filter bubble or echo chamber i don't
know i don't know
but that's kind of my question like is
there a downside to this
presumably it's the guests won't be
invited back maybe fox news will further
even limit the voices that are allowed
on the channel but um if guests started
doing this more regularly i think it
would be absolutely great and amazingly
this was not the only instance of a
guest
calling out the network on that network
yesterday
this example was from fox news i now
have one to look at
from newsmax so uh david litt
is a former barack obama speechwriter
i've interviewed him on the program
really interesting guy to talk to you
can check out
the youtube archives or the website
archives to find my interview with david
litt david litt
was invited to newsmax yesterday
presumably to talk about
elon musk's hosting of saturday night
live on saturday evening
and it went very similarly to the fox
news clip we looked at earlier of randy
weingarten
calling out fox news while on fox news
david lit went on newsmax and he called
them out
uh because of their deceptive and
outrageous coverage of the 2020 election
and i have to tell you this was done so
expertly
and it starts so subtly it's introduced
so
smoothly that it actually takes a second
for the newsmax host to even realize
what's going on
david lit says yeah you know saturday
night live they wrote stuff that wasn't
true
and they said it to their audience in
comedy format of course
and that's what newsmax did with the
2020 election coverage over the last
several months
it just wasn't comedy and this is how it
went
this one david lit good morning welcome
into wake up america nice to see you
thanks for having me um i did not watch
saturday night live i watched the clips
the show's on too late quite frankly i
don't think it's that funny anymore um
what do you think of elon musk's
performance this is the first time since
2015 we've had a non-athlete
non-entertainer on the show
the last person to do that and do well
with great ratings
our former president donald trump well
rob it's a great question i mean what
happened on snl this weekend was that
people
made stuff up and then said it on
television like it's true
and that actually happens pretty
frequently in american tv for example in
2020
dominion voting system sued newsmax over
its false claims
about election fraud newsmax was lying
to its own viewers and newsmax had to
settle
that lawsuit so i'm actually i just need
to check in are you still telling that
lie are you telling new lies
wait are we talking about i'm sorry
david are we talking about do you want
to talk about something completely
non-related and try to catch me on a
monday morning totally off topic or do
you want to talk about elon musk
i just love the reference from the host
to monday morning david lit you know
on a tuesday afternoon this would be
acceptable
how dare you try this on me on a monday
morning and this is actually something
that's done really frequently
when a host is pushed up against the
wall
or made uncomfortable they often will go
back to
this isn't what we booked you to talk
about i've sometimes done this as a
guest sometimes guests when the guest is
sandbagged
the guest will say you didn't book me to
talk about this
and it's a rhetorical crutch you just
have to be prepared for how to handle it
unless you've agreed not to talk about
something
um you just have to be prepared as the
host or as the guest
i've had situations we've had maybe two
or three situations where a guest
or their publicist will say listen
please don't
ask about x because there's ongoing
litigation
just can't comment on it and it's going
to bring the interview to a halt and of
course
i have the option as the host of saying
well i will ask about it but the guests
can say i'm not able to talk about that
right now
or it might not even really be a central
topic and i would say oh yeah that's not
the topic of the interview anyway
i've been on shows where they give me a
list of eight topics and say we might
talk about these things
and i have said before i don't know
anything about topic number five
so i'd rather not talk about it if you
ask me i'll just say i don't know about
that so i'm not the right person to ask
and we sort of come to an agreement
other than that it's basically just a
rhetorical game
and sometimes when a guest will turn
around and start asking the host
questions the host will do the i'm
asking the questions here you're here as
my guest
and then it's just sort of like a battle
of rhetoric there's no like set
rules about this it's really up for
interpretation
and here the host really comes off like
a loser quite frankly let's continue
well i can see why you don't want to
talk about dominion voting systems
because
if you do newsmax could get sued and
lose billions of dollars because these
are live
david david david that's listen
david that's fine david i know this is a
very funny moment for you i'm sure you
didn't sleep last night as you prepared
to sort of try and get the morning
anchor on newsmax
i'd be happy to talk with you about
whatever you want to talk about
obviously it's not the topic that we
have set up for right now
so if you'd like to talk about saturday
night live i will do that with you but
obviously i'm not going to talk about
anything else right now so you decide
right now in this moment on live
television go ahead
did dominion voting systems have any
impact on the 2020 election
oh that's unfortunate because i was
really excited about this interview i
didn't watch snl on saturday night but i
thought elon musk did an okay
job and he also said that he's got
asperger's so i thought that was a
fascinating component of the monologue
so david we look forward to having him
back
on very soon again that was a stellar
interview david litt thanks so much for
joining us
we'll be right back so yeah just cutting
off the interview
and it reminds me by the way the the
mention of asperger's or
as the host says ass burgers there's a
reason we no longer
say asperger's and instead say you know
high functioning autism or
low low severity autism spectrum
disorder
dr hans asperger did work linked to
nazism
nazi child psychiatry there's a debate
because asperger himself i guess was a
resistor
a nazi a resistor to the nazis but many
children that were identified by him
as having so-called aspergers were
subsequently killed by nazis
so i was actually surprised that elon
musk even used that term
to describe his own condition maybe
that's a topic for another day
i like what david lit did here it did
get cut off pretty quickly
but there's really no other way to
pierce the news max filter bubble
because otherwise you know you can talk
about newsmax on other channels
but going on newsmax and doing it there
i think it's fantastic i loved it for
for me it's perfect for a monday morning
monday morning is like the perfect day
to do what david did and quite frankly
it was kind of funnier than a lot of
recent saturday night live skits i have
not been super impressed
with snl recently um nice job by david
litt
and hopefully we'll have more of these
upcoming hey
here's an interesting topic that came in
via voicemail you can call the voicemail
number anytime
219 to david p here's a question about
mixed
status vaccination relationships whether
they are friendships
or whether they are romantic
relationships take a listen
hey david my name's carolyn i currently
live in ohio but i'm from connecticut
um anyways i wanted to ask you a
question on
um i guess how to deal with um
personal relationships and disagreements
on vaccines
so i have some friends that are not
taking it and um i'm actually
currently in the process of planning my
wedding which will be
not for a while it'll be the end of 2022
if everything
goes right um but i'm like wondering if
it's
safe to invite them but that it's gonna
cause a big falling out if i don't
um i'm just curious how you would
proceed if you were in my shoes
yeah so i actually so first of all on
the topic of the mixed
status relationship one person gets the
vaccine and the other is refusing it it
seems like a no-go to me to be perfectly
frank i don't know
it just seems like if only one person is
vaccinated as an
entity as a couple you're not really
vaccinated
the wedding question is an interesting
one i'm invited to multiple weddings
and none of them are are
checking vaccine certificates but these
are in the fall
they've said please don't come
if you are not vaccinated and it's
basically the honor system and i think
they probably have an understanding of
people aren't going to lie they'll
understand
if they only want vaccinated people and
i'm not vaccinated i i'm simply not
going to go so they've taken the
approach of invite but say we are asking
that everyone be vaccinated
so that we don't have to do masks and
everybody can just relax and have a good
time
that's probably what i would do let me
know your thoughts we've also got a
great bonus
show for you today you can get instant
access to it
by becoming a member at joinpakman.com
i'll see you then
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
blinkist is the app that helps you
become a more well-rounded person by
letting you read or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes
you can try it for free and get 25 off a
subscription
by going to blinkist.com david pakman